i am sitting in the morning i think i
listened to tom steiner probably 500
times a thousand times
3 000 times i don't recall
but awful
tom steiner was important for us in
creating mp3 because it sounded so bad
when we first coded it
[Music]
this is one of susan vega's most famous
songs
tom's diner
and it helped create the mp3 the audio
format that basically killed the cd
but who's better to show us how an
acapella track led to the rise of online
music sharing than the guy who created
it
my name is carl heinz gruntenberg most
people know me from my involvement in
the invention and development of mp3 so
in fact some people call me the father
of mp3
back in the 1980s carl hines was part of
a team working to develop a way to
compress music while still keeping its
high quality something that seemed
impossible at the time speech coding was
already well established
but if you try to code music with such a
speech coding algorithm it just sounded
horrible then one day i saw an article
where they discussed different
loudspeakers and how they tested them
they tested it with the acapella piece
tom steiner from ccd
so carl hines and his team decided to
use the same song to test their latest
compression algorithm but when they did
we managed to destroy susan vega's voice
let's see if you notice the difference i
am sitting in the morning at the diner
on the corner i am sitting in the
morning at the diner on the corner
while their algorithm had worked well
for most instruments there was one sound
it hadn't solved yet
the human voice they soon realized if
they could maintain audio quality on a
compressed version of susan's warm
vocals then they could compress any
music track
and turn out to
for the next i think a year or so to be
a major headache to us
after some tweaks here and there they
tuned up their algorithm and the mp3 was
born
for us when mp3 exploded and we found it
was one of the
most searched for terms on the internet
it was great finally we've done it
[Music]
and in fact that feeling goes until
today that sometimes i have to say is
that really true
if we look at mp3 and today's world of
digital audio
uh we have a simple saying mp3 works
everywhere
so the next time you stream a song
remember to thank susan vega and carl
hines the mother and father of the mp3
[Music]
you